un hemiciclo lleno de banderas
ucranianas se puso en pie para aplaudir
al presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski menos de 24 horas después de su
pedido formal para ingresar a la unión
europea
el líder participó de la sesión del
parlamento europeo con un mensaje claro
muy del samur
sin ustedes ucrania estará sola hemos
demostrado nuestra fuerza hemos
demostrado al menos que somos como
ustedes
y aquí
así que demuestran ustedes que están con
nosotros demuestran que no nos abandonan
y que son realmente europeos así la vida
vencerá a la muerte y la luz vencerá a
las tinieblas gloria a ucrania el
respaldo a su petición en la eurocámara
lo tiene asegurado la presidenta de la
comisión europea anunció que el bloque
destinará más de 500 millones de euros
para paliar las consecuencias
humanitarias de la guerra entonces
tenido su crimen ser el destino de
ucrania está en juego pero nuestro
propio destino también está en la
balanza al mes andrés sin más si king
tour iba y si putin busca dividir a la
unión europea debilitar a la otan y
romper la comunidad internacional ha
conseguido exactamente lo contrario
cif exact lady poder por su parte el
presidente del consejo europeo calificó
la invasión rusa de terrorismo
geopolítico
esto es terrorismo geopolítico puro y
duro
en un emotivo discurso el alto
representante de la unión europea en
asuntos exteriores pidió cancelar la
dependencia comunitaria de los
hidrocarburos rusos we will not
uy no vamos a abandonar la defensa de
nuestros derechos humanos y libertad
porque seamos más o menos dependientes
de rusia y tenemos que empezar a
trabajar rápido en el momento en el que
la comisión ha decidido empezar a
trabajar para cancelar su dependencia
esta comisión hast grupos nudo al tucán
su visita dependen si desde el apoyo al
mandatario ucraniano aún queda un largo
y burocrático camino a recorrer para que
la solicitud de adhesión de ucrania la
unión europea se efectúe